hey guys it's Jan here I've just seen
the new Deadpool movie and it's clear
right from the opening credits that
Deadpool knows exactly what kind of
movie it is and makes absolutely no
bones about it whatsoever yes this
Deadpool is super meta super chuki super
violent and super fun forget Green
Lantern Hal Jordan Wade Wilson aka
Deadpool is the comic book role that
Ryan Reynolds was born to play and i
don't mean the Merc with a sewn up mouth
who he saw an x-men origins wolverine
but the full-on potty-mouthed Merc with
filter free verbal diarrhea and a
chronic case of ADHD who Reynolds brings
to delirious life here with bags of
obnoxious charm and a sack full of sass
from start to finish Reynolds plays the
part perfection fully embracing
deadpool's fourth wall breaking world of
r-rated violence nudity and language
Reynolds completely carries the whole
movie on his shoulders and if you were
ever in any doubt that he was totally up
to that task you can't have seen his
gripping turn in the incredibly tense
thriller buried which featured Reynolds
alone on screen for 90 minutes with
nothing but a wooden coffin and lighter
and a cell phone to keeping company and
just as many of us can't imagine anyone
other than Robert Downey jr. as Iron Man
since he pulled on the exosuit back in
2008 as soon as you've seen Ryan
Reynolds as Deadpool you won't want
anyone else in that red costume and
frankly based on this film I hope they
make more Deadpool movies with Reynolds
in the lead as for the movie supporting
characters while deadpool's deliberately
overbearing personality puts everyone
else pretty much in the shade and
they're intentionally full of played up
stereotypes from Ed screens British
villain role as Deadpool's nemesis Ajax
to Corrin Sony's Indian taxi driver I
did enjoy the back and forth between
Deadpool and the total ECG created
Colossus who's voiced with the Russian
accent by Stefan kapitza and I really
loved brianna hildebrand as negasonic
teenage warhead and I definitely like to
see more of her in future movies TJ
Miller gets some nice interaction with
Deadpool as the Merc with a mouth pal
weasel while former anime star gina
carano gets to bust balls as age
his hyper strong henchwoman angel dust
as Wade Wilson's girlfriend Vanessa
Marano Bukharin is great she has good
chemistry with Reynolds and gives as
good as she gets I'd like to see her
character developed more and the same
goes for deadpool's flatmate blind al
who's played by Leslie Uggams though of
course this particular movie is mr. Paul
story not thurs director Tim Miller
who's known for his visual effects
commercials and video game work has done
a fantastic job in fact it's incredible
to think that this is his first feature
film note two x-men origins wolverine
directed gavin hood this is how you use
slow-mo not the overly melodramatic
rubbish we saw in Wolverines origin tale
Miller has put together a stylish film
and made it look as if the cast and crew
had an absolute ball making it the
movies 108 minutes speed by in a hail of
gunfire gags and profanity thanks to a
script by zombieland writers Rhett Reese
Paul Wernick which creatively more or
less masks the movies tight budget and
cleverly avoids the bit in a superhero
origin tale when we wait for the heroes
become you know super that the movies
story is pretty low stakes doesn't
really matter it's not so much about
what happens as it is about getting to
know and love this incarnation of the
stunningly self-aware comic book
character at the center of it all humor
comes thick and fast and covers all
points for the juvenile to the shrewdly
ironic so expect everything from the
scatological to slapstick
self-referential and more some of the
jokes didn't land for me but the sheer
volume of the meant that there was
usually something on the way pretty soon
that did in terms of other movies
Deadpool stylized violence hyper genre
awareness and superhero stick compare
favorably to the likes of kick-ass
Kingsman the Secret Service and James
Gunn's movie super so shut up crime the
old-school vibe of the movie soundtrack
which is a suitably eclectic mix of
everything from rap to easy listening an
80s pop to soft rock reminded me of
guardians of the galaxy while the movies
original score is by junkie XL who also
scored the insanely inspired Mad Max
fury road as you'd imagine there's a
shedload of Easter eggs and references
to the comic books at the movies and
general pop culture in fact I'll have a
lot
discussion about that in my next video
which I'll add a link to hear when it's
ready for you to watch Owen expect a
pretty cool cameo for Stanley some very
Deadpool animated credits and also a
little something after the credits
oscar-winning costume designer anger
strathy and production designer Sean
howarth who's working of seen in the
recent goosebumps movie have done some
fine work creating deadpool's world and
makeup designer bill Corso who
transformed Steve Carell for the movie
fox capture has done similarly still a
work again in this movie especially with
Wade Wilson's post workshop look I also
want to give a shout-out to the movie
stunt coordinators Robert Alonzo and
Phillip silveira who between them of
work done movies including Star Trek
Iron Man and netflix is daredevil series
the fragmented fight scenes and action
sequences and Deadpool are top-notch so
to sum up Tim Miller's Deadpool movie is
the best Deadpool movie that chimi
Changa live in comic book fans could
have wished for its star is pretty much
pitch perfect its action and violence on
loud and proud it's language is totally
untamed and its tongue is very firmly in
its cheek as it takes a full frontal
swipe at superhero cliches while merrily
making the most of them itself Deadpool
gets 4 out of 5 flicks now what are you
looking forward to most about Deadpool
or if you've seen it already what did
you think let me know in the comments
below I've got a video looking at the
movies behind-the-scenes secrets here
and they'll be a link here to my dead
Paul Easter Egg video when it's ready as
always do please like leave your
comments and share this video and hit
that subscribe button for more videos
like this thanks for watching and see
you next time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
you